[Music]
this week we've got bong protest but
slick getaway but and chopped penis but
take it away honey yeah so for our first
story there's this man named Jeffrey you
cannot say it would use the name gently
like it's stuck like that Jeff so he was
standing outside of the police station
protesting saying that he wants the
police station to return his bong and to
return his weed what the [ __ ]
Westy this isn't a weed legal state yeah
this is in Canada so he does have a
medical marijuana card oh and so he was
saying that at the time that he got
arrested he did have it with him but the
cops still confiscated his bong and his
weed and so he was upset about that and
so he started protesting outside the
police station in a really bright speedo
type of thing what he really wants that
bong packed with his bong this guy he
looks higher return my bong
quintessential pothead like look at him
is that sign floating oh my god he's has
more signs to sign and so since he got
arrested twice the second time that he
got arrested they did return his bong
and his weed but he's protesting for
that first time that he got arrested
okay yeah I just know this this
underwear is a regular brief underwear
maybe tied in the corners to make it a
panty like the girls yeah cuz we used to
do that when we used to go good answer
he knows what he's doing oh the guys
protesting a twenty dollar plastic ball
like a really pretty multi-tool and like
it's crazy
well that's look at the one they took
from him oh how amazing is the one that
they took from them and how much weed
and how amazing like what kind of strand
it looks like Jack's off to weird [ __ ]
yeah I mean like you don't want to look
at his search histories in the cookies
yeah I said that he started protesting
with his clothes on and stuff but he
wasn't getting enough attention so
that's when he decided we turned my
marijuana yeah he did some research on
like indecent exposure laws and he so he
was able to undress like the most he
could without getting in trouble
that's smart that's how you give
attention I did it that's why we get
views for our Channel
there you go yeah I used to work for a
nice to be us a brand ambassador model
for a glass pipe company to call exhaust
pipe na bong no those crazy dude they
get [ __ ] like multi gel dragons and
like different chambers yeah insane this
guy may he blue glass and it's like a
full-on ak-47 they can smell [ __ ]
beautiful that's awesome what the [ __ ]
would you do with this you know I think
like smoke shops don't like it to be
called a bong well they yeah cuz they
call them it's it's for tobacco use yeah
they call it water pipes water pipes
there you go
when marijuana was illegal recently
they're just water pipes for tobacco yes
I got a lot of attention his photos went
viral did he get it back so the last I
heard was that the cops acknowledged him
what does that mean pretty much thing
like you could guess Jeff we acknowledge
you and your problems will be address
will look into it
Canada's so sweet hmm this is like my
Donald's in us we acknowledge you we
know you're there dun dun dun say us
they acknowledge
gift.you and they invite you to the
whole bunch of boys that's where there's
one girl
oh what a [ __ ] loyalty for Allah you
know why though they follow me on insta
they follow me on Twitter but they don't
recognize me they just lurk no I moved
past McDonald's do though I don't talk
about it that's why they sent me stuff
because you guys don't send creepy
messages enough just did you message
them no I just I tweet them periodically
just really creepy things like
borderline creepy not like don't matter
man like the comments speak for itself
like that's what it's about and this
whole time like you ignore me like I'm
not there that's [ __ ] cool I'll burn
your house and that's it I feel like I'm
that fan from Eminem music you know I'm
Stan you know how like crazy fandoms
they a stan is someone like if I'm like
a stand of David I'm like oh I stand him
that means like I'm the Eminem stand of
David like that's a good actually
it took that long like they're called
like Beyonce crazy fans like Beyonce's
stands or you know like it's a it's a
noun you know I was listening to that
song like the other day and then you
know how the song is going through the
fans what he's going through at the time
but it's funny because he killed himself
right in the song but how did he get the
letter then cuz he was writing as he was
driving her some [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't
make sense yeah just kidding okay so I
just heard this last night back in like
be my space Asian Avenue whatever days
you guys remember the song smoke weed by
Khmer kid yeah I heard it yesterday I
realized how much I used to love it so
it has a kid it is so good that's I got
it I got it yeah I don't remember that
one
I'm pretty sure if I play it you'll
remember it
that's the way it goes in the background
yeah I don't know what ha it was a
really good song yeah yeah you know
talking everyone's that agent Avenue
playlist is an Asian song yeah it's it's
from the late 90s early 2000 like Asian
rap days like there's a handful of songs
you know you got the tie my shoe mm-hmm
he had two songs
before I like those guys
all right Brian next story there was
this woman who ended up slipping out of
her handcuffs when she was behind the
police car and drove off in the police
car oh yeah I didn't purposely Asian
lady huh small hands white Florida lady
Texas
her name is Pocius pond slur you should
have been more responsible
how does she get her whoa
I should double join it or something in
her hand 23 minute car chase she dodged
him gangster damn that looks [ __ ] fun
she's an outlaw oh she's trying to get
the shotgun oh oh you're about to get
shot oh she had a shot good news she was
trying to grab the shotgun that was
locked inside of the cart also they had
a blast her ass
what no they ended up breaking the
window and if she was black she be dead
hundred percent my cashews why they
didn't sign those cuffs I don't know if
she's white what is she is panic I think
she no but her last name is sponsor Wow
what is that machine it looks like she
used to be black and then she bleached
her skin and then maybe she's half black
half white well she could be I could see
that I don't know what the hell she is
she just found crack yeah she was like a
crack in it that's the face of crack
though that's a Haunter percent the face
of meth and crack that's not a black
person crying that's a white person
crying right there shoplifting that's it
she was a mess the only reason why she
panicked and went crazy is because she's
on meth or crime you totally settled
with the shoplifting now you got [ __ ]
grand theft and what is it oh she got
charged with five felony counts of
escape with the threat of a deadly
weapon
aggravated assault unauthorized use of a
vehicle possession of a controlled
substance and evading arrest what was
she trying to steal sudafed codeine
chocolate she got caught for stealing
socks and mash yeah what is she trying
still diapers or something for a baby
that shot down because her door was
locked in the house now and she need to
bust the door but I got you
she needs to be arrested for being ugly
dude she is [ __ ] hideous me what the
thing is we know a lot before counts of
being ugly but that's the face of meth
that is I love seeing those like before
and after meth they're [ __ ] crazy oh
there's some really beautiful people
that really look like which is it like
Smeagol with hair like really beautiful
people I end up getting a shits in a
face tattoo I wonder you know cuz like
when we see this stuff not because like
what we've seen on media I really do
wonder if that was a black woman if she
would have got away so either she's
waiting for her shotgun that's like she
would have died she would have died if
you're if you're black it would have
shot in the window if you're if you're
not white I feel like even like a
Hispanic like a brown or black dude like
there's there's light the cops don't
like that and yeah I wonder if you're
like Cambodian because you're like Asian
black yeah you're like the darker is
yeah but they don't know what you are
dude just dad what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do you know you think they
would have shot her without even pulling
the gun on them as soon as she touches
actually that's true
I still think so it's the attempt it's
the intention behind it it's like the
the skit and Family Guy at the TSA when
they have a chart that has skin colors
like which was accepted the light ones
the dark ones are not like just hold up
sir I would have just turned the dog in
the door card you know how hard it is to
see a canine dog and not pet it yeah
they don't let you I just go up like
this like smell my hand yeah this girl
she was able to have the cops go on a 23
minute chase it's crazy and she was even
able to sort did you guys see how they
put the the spike moving for the tires
and she was able to swerve it she's been
playing Grand Theft Auto I know
I started to turn on the siren if I have
another hey what if she was trying to
drink there's too many buttons what the
situation is how did you slip through
it's crazy
maybe they didn't put it on tight enough
that [ __ ] hurts yeah I think she just
has one of those thumbs that you could
squeeze yeah she's stable they do some
weird [ __ ] with their know is there any
way you can like flex your wrist while
they're putting it on and then you can
Oh smart they just they didn't put it on
tight enough they're trying to be polite
they're trying to be polite yep well
furnace it through the backseat window
those are pretty small I mean yeah think
so after she got caught I have the cop
see up another video of them like
screwing in like the to completely seal
that cage thing and then they put
hashtag fool me once because they're
like you're not vegan so for our last
story that was this wife
in South Korea that was really upset
because her husband apparently was
watching way too much golf or was
playing too much golf Oh
and so she just got really upset with
her man and ended up chopping off his
dick that's why you [ __ ] stay away
from Korean girls the Korean girls our
passion is so they're crazy but they're
also very loving I just got to keep them
on the loving side and you got to stop
watching golf so much Malus she's boring
it's blue cream Island scary
I dated up being go before it was very
interesting I remember she called me
just to say I love you more than you
love me so we're gonna break up and if
she hung up on me and in three seconds
later she picked up as
it sounds like what the [ __ ] just
happened
it's hard to shake off Korean girls dude
I broke up with one and I try to walk
away from her she just kept following me
the next day she showed up at my work
what happened and then the next day show
up a man who's it the girl that I knew
or is it the same girl was it oh no I
was like crazy
my friend had this young Korean girl
it's funny because that girl happens to
be friends with my cousin and my friends
like this 30 something year old really
well-established guy and she got so
crazy about him after hanging out with
him a couple times she waited in the
bushes of his complex like apartment
complex and when he went out she like
stabbed him in the arm oh [ __ ] that
makes sense
she wants to damage him so nobody else
can have him it's like a discount sure
to just rip the pocket that's exactly
what she's trying to do she left her
mark dude because apparently she flushed
it's gone forever bye bye dick damn you
know though I would say this though
that's lightweight the dudes fault
because there's no like sudden like this
girl was sweet the whole time like was a
perfect wife and that she was like I'm a
thief like it was you know and you
decide to marry that so be careful for
what you put your dick in you don't put
your dick in a toaster you also don't
put it in the cream or yeah to a Korean
lady she is who she's sold a nest camera
in their house so when she goes out with
her friends she's like she can talk to
this stop playing video game so much go
do this go do that
yeah she was [ __ ] insane it's insane
when I talk about the craziest one the
wedding I went to Hawaii it's a
relationship it's a wedding that we all
made a pool see how long it'll last
it's that bad mm-hmm is this so lasting
uh it's been since May
yeah but we're already starting to hear
complaints like filing maybe Korean
girls can't be with a nice boy they have
to be with a controlling boy
no no kill each other they have to be
not a nice boy that they can control all
sorts of balance mm-hmm
so one is the control II mm-hmm can't
control me [ __ ]
are you making me work with Mary oh
she's not like that she's not like that
she's crazy and like Oh in a weird sense
she's not crazy in a violent sense well
she won't do anything bad like that but
she's crazy and says she makes things up
in her own head girls like to pick and
choose what they want to use in the
memory span it's like I only remembered
this but you don't remember the full
sentence he's remember that one part of
the train you guys it's true they have
selective memory oh you guys my memory
is perfect people have been harassing
him for the last year yeah but to be to
be really really like honest with you
guys can't remember dates dates is what
we Cameron I don't know why it's like so
natural for ladies to remember moments
dates and all these things right like
for guys I can't I don't even know my
mom's birthday
do you even know your everything I do
but I forget sometimes my age yes I'm
right there - I've been forgetting my
age lately no me too like we stopped
counting at the 25 houses subtract this
year and my birthday figure it out
that's how bad I forgot I even forgot
the other day I had a baby doctor
appointment with Christina and she calls
me like where are you I'm like I'm two
blocks away from home it's like we're
supposed to be at the appointment now
like at that exact moves let's be at the
dock yeah and I was it like an hour away
what a shitty
very I just can't remember everything I
don't know why I think we're just as
sentimental shouldn't wake up one day
like where's the baby well what the [ __ ]
were you pregnant forget the kid on the
roof oh no I won't do that maybe at
school but yeah my definite got me a
school alive yeah hey guys would you
think of that video I know you loved it
so make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos and check it out up
here
[Music]